the Joe Rogan experience me too
let's party that's a really interesting
no if I can make a superfight if I was
like Dana scrooge mcduck there's sin on
top all these gold coins
I'd call it been asking like yo any
interest in fighting could be but 170
[ __ ] yes [ __ ] whatever that's what I'm
talking yes that's the fire boy boy I'm
gonna tell you talks like calls we call
your boy he buck you girl I don't call
him but I'm sure you collect yelling to
him this weekend I want to talk to him
this weekend that would be the fight but
you know the one who tried to get one
here's a thing would have been aspirin
wins they starts talking [ __ ] calling
Dana Murphy [ __ ] perfect
egghead it works it sells papers it's
the bottom line yeah but then you've
ruined could be if been asking could be
I think you give Ben Askren a guy who's
a good fighter GSP well yeah but seeing
it most people don't know who Ben Askren
is the problem is he fought in Bellator
for so long and then even when Bellator
has gotten bigger on Spike TV he was off
in one Fc
which you have known we are huge Ben
Askren fans now but we're hardcore like
the the casual fan has no idea like
who's this guy with the curly hair
they're sending to his death but we can
sell it because he speaks well he's
about beast on the mind yeah and then
you pin I forget an Olympian yeah he's
never who's on if he had never been hit
against right khabib yeah and we call it
the cold why thinking the UFC
particularly me I'm a Big Ben Askren
dick Rider and Jimmy Smith who's also a
Big Ben Askren dick we're all different
were all the riders we could sell the
[ __ ] out of it I could hype the [ __ ] out
of it--and to be a hundred percent
honest in the process I think he's
something special I think his grappling
is very unusual very difficult to
prepare for and if you're gonna deal
with khabib against a guy who can
neutralize his stuff and then we see
like what if we see khabib on his back
Ben Askren [ __ ] with a knee across
the belly punching khabib in the face
well like no right just doing the ground
in pound
alright there's these trait crazy up
scrambles and grappling community seem
like it would be amazed as terrible
striking good luck selling that to uncle
Dana zombie [ __ ] off of a [ __ ]
ooh he's gonna slam that phone down [ __ ]
you he would have to have he's like sir
I'm trying to finalize see him Punk
Floyd here an aspirin - beep how dare
you he would have to have a good
relationship with Ben Askren they would
have no he does not ease I disagree
he doesn't know he can go all right I
make money off this kid I have four and
fifty million dollars they make money
off this kid let me do this don't you
think you'd have to put Ben Askren in a
UFC fight though against some money to
show everybody what he's capable of hope
he has all those belts undefeated
Olympian we just promo the [ __ ] with
he's on embedded he's on you see at
night
he's on below the belt he's on JRE we go
on this campaign he's dressed in a flag
you can watch me beat the [ __ ] out of
great Russian who else not like Russia
yeah great whoo I like it it's never
happening right that's never happening
but you sold me thank you just get Dan
to listen to this video Dana
uncle D if you just have him fight
someone who's really good like a Neil
Magny or Carlos Condit have him up like
[ __ ] kobayashi toss that introduction
fight and who knows nope this is a
one-shot Hail Mary we're selling the
[ __ ] out of it because they want to be
fight still make your cross Connor and
just like rape some hump some four three
rounds people if that's sock man I know
but he probably won't be able to like
khabib so you gotta watch that one we
missed the his style is so much more
suited to one Fc because they allow
those knees to the head on the ground
true soccer kicks and what they still
have soccer kicks and what I've seen
[Applause]